[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen sallys welt
heute gibt es einen nachgemacht rezept
ich werde auf euren wunsch hin einen
papageien kuchen machen
der kuchen sieht nicht aus wie ein
papagei sondern er ist einfach nur bunt
und im anschnitt sie sahen aus wie sein
papa kann fällt deswegen heißt es oh da
gibt es eine berühmte backmischung dazu
ich habe jetzt nicht gekauft weil ich
mir gedacht komm dafür brauchen jetzt
keine bot mischung und ich brauche ich
jetzt auch nicht zeigen
ich mache jetzt einfach das rezept das
ganze mache ich jetzt als blechkuchen so
habt ihr sozusagen einen kraut wieder
und könnt dann mit diesen kuchen eine
große kraut als eine große menschenmasse
füttern da kommt auch der name und es
ist ein cooler geburtstagskuchen
kindergeburtstag fasching bereit jetzt
einfach zu vor allem ist der teig so
vereinfachen ist nämlich ein ganz
normaler rührteig der einfach nur
eingefärbt werden
für den ritt brauche ich 250 gramm
weiche butter 250 gramm zucker eine
prise salz etwas man den extrakt sechs
zimmer war mayer 400 gramm mehl etwas
mit drei teelöffel backpulver und
lebensmittel verpassten
und da wirklich auch verpassten nehmen
keine flüssigen farben zum einen sind
die verpassten farbintensiver man kann
sie mit packungen also sie verändern
ihre farbe nicht wir sind geschmacks und
geruchsneutral und vor allem verändern
sie die konsistenz nicht weil es eben
der paste ist und nichts flüssiges okay
so viel zur theorie
jetzt starte ich gleich damit die
zutaten müssen alle zimmer waren seien
also vor allem die butter und die eier
und die milch die werde ich jetzt gleich
noch erwärmen
damit sie lauwarm ist jetzt kann ich
hier die weiche butter rühren
zusammen mit dem zucker salz und weil
extrakt und jetzt hier die butter zucker
masse einfach wie etwa fünf bis sechs
minuten richtig schön weiß cremig will
in der zwischenzeit werde ich schon mal
die milch erwärmen
[Musik]
jetzt ist die butter zucker masse schön
cremig und ich gebe es die eier dazu
immer 1 1 nach dem anderen
schön erst mal einfallen lassen für eine
halbe minute etwa
und dann das nächste kugel
[Musik]
kann ich hier das backpulver mit dem
mehl vermischen und stand einfach
abwechselnd mit der milch viel zum teig
dazu geben
danke
das mini aquarium grube stelle ich mich
in die küche
danke
und jetzt einfach nur darauf achten dass
er nicht mehr so lange rührt sobald das
mehl dabei ist damit der kuchen nicht
speckig wird sondern schön locker wird
also wirklich nur noch kurz bis sich
alles verbunden hat und jetzt habe ich
den größten part erstmal erledigt der
basis teig ist fertig und jetzt teile
ich ihnen auch verschiedene schälchen
auf und kann ihn doch noch einfärben
[Musik]
ihr seht ihr teig konsistenz ist nicht
flüssig aber auch nicht zu fest und
jetzt kommen hier die farben dazu ich
habe sechs schönsten gemacht aber
schönen bunten kuchen und jetzt einfach
ein bisschen farbe dazu geben daraus
nicht auch schneidend ist ganz frisch
die sind super ich hatte sogar eine
zeitlang für jede farbe einen einen
richtigen teixeira dazu das ist schon
verrückt jetzt auch gar nicht so lange
wählen sondern nur so bis verbunden sind
[Musik]
und hier beim einfärben einfach nur
darauf achten
jetzt zieht die farbe zwar noch relativ
hell aus aber durchs backen wird der
kuchen einfach nur ein bisschen dunkler
also die farbe wird noch intensiver
da habt ihr wirklich ganz wenig nur
kannst rosa machen
dann wünsche ich noch aus großer
brauchen ein bisschen mehr das stimmt
[Musik]
jetzt nämlich ein backblech nehmen
lochblech mit einer dauerhaft folie und
einen bug rahmen ihr könnt auch ein ganz
normales backblech benutzen so backt der
kuchen einfach schön gleichmäßig und ihr
habt direkt den rechten winkel hier
außen und jetzt kommt der teig einfach
fleckig hier rein
das heißt ein bisschen hier ein bisschen
davon und gar nicht so sehr vermissen
[Musik]
jetzt ehrt dahin wohl noch nichts
wenn man sich zu achse märz einfach nur
braun wir wollen ja die schön fertig
sein
[Musik]
denn jetzt doch ein bisschen eng
zusammen dass der kuchen ein bisschen
kompakter und höher wird das könnte
jetzt hier ganz gut ablesen
50 mal 30 jetzt einfach ein bisschen nur
verstreichen so dass einfach der drei
gleichmäßig hoch ist aber nicht so sehr
verstreichen
[Musik]
jetzt kommt das schon in den backofen in
folge heizung war doch nicht schwer oder
[Musik]
ja
stäbchen profis sagt noch so 23 minuten
guckt ein bisschen was dran aber
donnerstag
unser papageien gucken ist jetzt
abgekühlt ich finde eigentlich komisch
ist das heißt aber mittlerweile in wird
man solche bunten kuchen immer
regenbogen kuchen bin in den papageien
kuchen und jetzt kommt eine zuckerglasur
drauf mit puderzucker und zitrone möchte
ich den zitronensaft drei interessen und
drückt man schönen dickflüssigen saft
dickflüssigen burghausen rendezvous an
der seine
so ein richtig schöner dickflüssiger
guss der zieht dann nämlich auch nicht
ein sondern bleibt eine zuckerschicht
auf der oberfläche
wer möchte kann den jetzt auch noch
einfärben aber das machen wir jetzt
nicht vergessen denen sie drauf rechts
zu gießen
und jetzt am besten direkt so und beide
stellen müssen also
[Musik]
jetzt schön verteilen
da muss man nur aufpassen man muss zwar
ein bisschen drücken aber nicht so sehr
das wächst die oberste kuchen schicht
nicht abgelöst wird deswegen nicht so
oft drüber fahren ist wie so ein
bisschen fingerspitzengefühl gefragt es
geht auch mit einem pinsel nicht ganz so
gut mit einem pinsel macht man er die
kugel oberfläche kaputt und jetzt
einfach nur noch weg und kettenraucher
der stoff du hast es aus wenn ich noch
die packung ich hab's schon dass eine
serie hingelegt hat sich haben war
konfetti aus esspapier erst zum
aufreißen und jetzt kannst du in die
hand nehmen und darüber streuen
[Musik]
ja und jetzt auch michael zucker
konfetti und perfekt lassen wir den bus
fest werden und damit der kuchen gleich
aus dem back rahmen gelöst und
angeschnitten das reichte frei laufen
konzentrieren
[Musik]
mainz rausnehmen musste und jetzt sieht
jedes tortenstück anders aus
[Musik]
der kuren sind es sieht schon mega gut
ausprobieren ob ihr könnt das ich auch
wie bei dem zitronenkuchen bisschen
zitronenschalen noch in den teig dazu
geben
lecker
lecker und saftig ist der kuchen
da steht auch schon probiert ja weißt du
wieder heißt der kuchen papageien koch
und weißt du auch warum
ja weil es wie ein papagei und findest
du dass unsere zuschauer den kurven mal
ausprobieren sollten
und der passt ja auch perfekt in die
faschingszeit oder ja ich finde ich auch
vor allem mit konfetti obendrauf
also wenn jetzt das nachmachen wollen
findet er ist auch sehr ließ - blockte
eben oder in einer kostenlosen app jetzt
gerne mal auf und ihr seht die farben
die kommen echt wunderschöne raus also
viel spaß und nach bagger dann bis zum
nächsten mal
[Musik]
erst papier schlusslicht ist